MALE SPEAKER: Hey.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming
to this talk today.
My name is [? Chris. ?]
This is going to be a very
interesting talk about how we
can fix our transportation
crisis, which everybody knows
is getting worse and worse,
especially as the Bay Area
economy heats up and our G-buses
from San Francisco and
other places get slower
and slower.
I'd like to start by thanking
the Google Green Team and
Talks at Google for helping to
organize and sponsor this.
Without them, it wouldn't really
have been possible.
And it also wouldn't have been
possible without several
people who did invaluable work
to help me promote and
organize the talk and help to
bring you who are here today
to this room.
So thank you very much
for all of that.
Our speaker today is Stuart
Cohen, who is the executive
director of TransForm, which is
a local nonprofit based out
of Oakland that's been
there since 1997.
And their mission is to help
promote and achieve better
transportation and land use
planning practices for all the
communities and the government
in California through whatever
ways they can to help
achieve that.
And he'll explain in this talk
a lot of the ways in which
TransForm has had some successes
in the past, what
the challenges are that remain,
and what can be done
in the future.
Stuart is an amazing speaker,
as you'll see in a few
minutes, and also is proud
to be a Ashoka fellow.
Ashoka is a social
entrepreneurship prize that's
offered every year that comes
with a certain amount of money
to help that social entrepreneur
achieve things.
It started in India and now
has a lot of support,
actually, from Sergey Brin and
his wife, who have a matching
gift every year.
I'd like to help join you in a
round of applause for Stuart.
And we'll hear about
transformation of
transportation.
[APPLAUSE]
STUART COHEN: Thanks.
Well, thank you.
And it's fabulous to be here.
So I wanted to-- and this could
probably be a little
lower, I tend to scream--
I wanted to welcome you
all here today.
In addition to some of the
Google staff, we do have some
elected officials who
showed up today.
And I just wanted
to welcome them.
We have the Mayor of Mountain
View is here, Mike Kasperzak.
The Vice Mayor, Margaret
Abe-Koga is here.
Tom Means and Tara
Martin-Milius, who's from
Sunnyvale, are also here.
So wanted to just thank you for
welcoming us in the community.
And I think they're here and
you're here, because we are in
a terrible crisis
in many ways.
And it's a slow crisis.
The talk was billed as a "how do
we solve the transportation
crisis," but I think, as you're
going to see, it's
about a lot more
than that, too.
And I needed to get a
sub-heading for this talk, and
I think you'll see I did an AKA,
which I never do on my
presentations.
But how do we create healthy,
affordable, low greenhouse gas
communities is, to me, the same
thing as, how do we solve
our transportation crisis?
So just as background--
so I got into transportation
from the seat of a bicycle.
I was given a bicycle.
I was organizing against toxic
waste disposal in upstate New
York, given a bicycle
by my sister.
I said, oh, I haven't been
on one of these in years.
I just drive from community to
community in upstate New York,
and then moved to New
York City for a job.
And the place that should really
be the best place in
the world for commuting--
totally flat and everything's
within a few miles--
turned out to be one of the most
dangerous and harrowing
experiences, even though I did
it for three years straight,
even through snowstorms.
And so when I came out to
California, started
researching the problems,
working on, actually, 1994
climate issues, and going back
to grad school at Berkeley and
finishing in '97 with my dream
of thinking, how do we solve
this puzzle?
How do we change our
transportation system in a way
that actually becomes a servant
to the things we care
about, whether it's saving
the environment, helping
low-income folks get around,
creating great communities,
instead of the master that
has become of us.
And so that's a little bit of
what my talk's going to be.
I just wanted to get a
sense of this crowd,
though, real quickly.
How many folks were able to
get here without use of a
private, single-occupant
vehicle today?
Just raise your hand if you
showed up that way.
Yeah, which is right.
So we've got a good cross
section of Googlers here,
because about half of the
Google community gets to
Mountain View without having
to drive alone, which is
unbelievably good for a Mountain
View campus like
this, much more similar to the
kind of rates that you would
see in downtown San Francisco.
So I think there's a lot to
learn from folks at Google.
But let's get going on
to the presentation.
This is some of the most early
forms of transit, actually,
mid-1850s and '60s.
And what I'm going to do is
start with the breadth of
history and where the challenges
have taken us, go
into some of those solutions
that we hope to see taking
place, and then invite you to
help think through some of the
opportunities over the next one
to three years to really
have an impact on our
transportation system.
This kind of transit here is
complemented by a street
system that you can see-- this
very early street system of
San Francisco--
that had everything really
close together.
This is, in planner's circles,
known as a grid.
This grid got kind of disrupted
as the World War II
veterans were coming back, and
they started building these
Levittowns--
first on Long Island, where I
grew up, and then, here's in
Pennsylvania--
which really separated people
from the other needs of their
life and pretty much
relied on cars.
This was the first time, really,
communities were built
thinking you'd have to have
a car to get around.
And what that ushered in was
this whole era when we thought
automobiles are going
to dominate how
people get around fully.
This was a plan for San
Francisco that was going to
crisscross it with
major freeways.
And this is what it would have
looked like through much of
San Francisco.
For those of you who are newer
to the region, you might enjoy
the Ferry Building with
the farmers market.
And this is what it looked like
when I first came to the
Bay Area, before they
took down the
freeway after the quake.
So anyway, what happened,
because of all of the land use
happening in this way that
relied on cars, is that
funding for things like public
transit declined as we needed
more money for roads.
And so even when we tried to
build public transit and have
people be able to get around,
it would turn out that if we
built too many of our-- either
shopping centers or, in this
case, the Cisco campus--
this way, you
actually can't get around.
Over here, you'll see a
light rail station.
Very, very few people use it,
because you get out and it's
kind of "which is my office
park" kind of feeling to it.
And so that line, $400 million
gets about 4,000 riders a day.
And so finally, they started
building homes further than
the Levittowns.
This is a sign from the Central
Valley, where some of
the best, prime farmland in this
world is getting plowed
under at an amazing rate for
these kind of garages for
folks to come in.
Some of the impacts of this,
starting with social impacts--
we're driving, compared to 1969,
88% further just to shop
for the same quart of milk
and longer for errands.
And I put this picture up here
because this is a new
three-screen vehicle where each
of these screens can show
different things to the
different crowds in the car.
You see the little girl's almost
drooling out of the
side of her mouth as the
world goes by there.
And that's how kids are growing
up these days--
totally don't know how to get
around their own town.
And in the car review magazine,
they said that this
new three-screen set-up, where
they can watch cartoons in the
front but more sophisticated
movies in the back, is a boon
to parents.
Because when you're waiting at
that drive-through, you won't
get those kids crying as much.
But here's the clicker.
They've got one of
these babies.
The driver can control all three
screens at once with a
remote control, so the kids
don't have to figure that out.
Holy distracted driving,
right?
So there's real social
impacts.
This is-- we see the obesity
epidemic following the same
lines as the growth
in driving.
Diabetes, asthma from air
pollution, a lot of these are
growing tremendously, and a lot
of it related to lack of
physical activity, air pollution
from vehicles.
And in almost all of these
slides that you see, there is
a layer that the folks most
impacted are low-income,
typically people of color, who
have the least ability to
either move out of polluted
places or, for a variety of
other reasons, get the
worst of the impacts.
So here's the thing, also, is
that we are now paying an
amazing amount of money out of
people's own pockets for
transportation.
Here you can see, in this map,
the spread-out areas in dark
pay the most money for
transportation.
Places along those red lines,
which is the high-transit,
walkable communities, pay up to
60% less, because they're
able to own fewer vehicles.
But again, here's a slide.
The hardest hit are low-income
families.
This is an amazing and shocking
statistic, but 31% of
the income in low-income
families right now, making
$20,000 to $30,000, go to
transportation, because so
many jobs are out of reach.
Around eight out of nine jobs
created during the '90s, you
needed a car to get to,
within half an hour.
That's become part of it.
And here's something
that hopefully
people think about more.
I know, over at Google,
is an important thing,
is the carbon impacts.
38% of our global warming
emissions are now from
transportation.
And I just got back from New
York yesterday and was able to
witness some of the devastation
from Superstorm Sandy.
And it was really
unbelievable.
And this was very much
what was predicted.
The climate scientists, working
with others, had said,
get ready for these
storm surges.
We don't know when they're
coming, but they're coming.
You can see some of
the pictures.
This is the subways flooding.
This is the train tracks
being covered.
This is my wife's hometown,
on the right,
devastated in the Rockaways.
And this is some of the new
subway stations that they had
built downtown--
inundated, absolutely
inundated.
And we can't blame this on
global warming, per se, but
this is one of my
favorite quotes.
It's a little bit like in
baseball, where you can't say
that any particular home run was
because of the steroids.
But when somebody's hitting 20
and 30 more home runs than
they did a few years ago,
some of them are.
And we're going to see the
frequency of these kind of
storms increase.
Sea levels are already rising,
seven inches higher than they
were under the Golden Gate
Bridge a century ago.
This is a little bit scary, but
this is going to be the
Bay Area with 16-inch
sea level rise,
which is going to happen.
It's a matter, again, of
how quickly it happens.
This is a zooming-in.
I thought folks might be
interested in what Mountain
View is going to be
looking like.
And you could actually see
part of Moffett Field--
I won't go into it here--
and parts of this campus.
The dark blue is the 55-inch sea
level rise without storm
surges' inundation.
Going back and seeing this
happen to my wife's place that
she grew up in, where they
never thought about this,
really brought home the fact
that we're going to be living
in a world with this.
So here is the good part,
before getting totally
depressed, is that we really
can do something about it.
Those same places that we're
paying a lot of money are also
emitting a lot of carbon
emissions.
And so if we can grow in those
areas that are these lighter
colors, we can dramatically
reduce
the amount of emissions.
In fact, in terms of transit
use, folks that are living and
working near transit in the Bay
Area take it for 42% of
their work trips.
Folks that live or work
more than half a mile
away take it for 4%.
So there's a 10 times change if
we can grow differently and
grow around transit.
These are the Bay Area stats.
There's a dramatic
difference in it.
And here's the other good
news, is you're
not forced to live--
not that forcing somebody to
live in San Francisco is a bad
thing-- but you're not forced to
live in really urban areas.
Some of these little yellow
dots that have--
this is the town of Windsor.
They've created this
wonderful downtown.
It's north of Santa Rosa, in
that place where they are able
to bring together shops and
arts and crafts and now
they're bringing living
around it.
They're dramatically reducing
the distance
people have to drive.
So even in more rural areas, if
you grow smart, grow around
downtowns the way we used
to, we can have an
impact on all this.
And I wanted to put this
slide in, because
this is really important.
This shows the amount of money
we are spending out of our own
pockets, collectively,
on transportation.
And if all of the neighborhoods
had the same
level of public transit access
as those ones in yellow, as
those really low ones with
good transit access--
in the Bay Area, we would be
spending $10 billion less a
year on transportation out of
our pockets and emitting 42%
less greenhouse gas emissions.
And so when we think of how we
can find money to fix the
system, the money's actually
in our pockets.
And we have to think of how we
spend money smarter to do it.
I just wanted to frame that as
some of the issues and the
problems with transportation,
and get on to a little bit of
what TransForm has done, and
then get into the current day.
So when we started in '97, we
came into a system that was
caught up in that
self-fulfilling prophecy of
sprawl that I showed.
We actually projected--
these dots here are the
projections for housing units
in the Bay Area in 1997.
We thought that most of the
housing was going to be going
to those dark red areas, the
dark blue areas-- high-cost,
high-emission areas.
And we knew what that
would bring.
We knew that if you put highways
to it-- and a lot of
money was going to be going
to highways to feed it--
they were going to be clogged,
costs were going to be high,
and we were going to be having
an increase in congestion of
about 800% on some of
our roads, because
people had no choices.
We said, this is lunacy.
But the transportation
agency--
MTC, it's our regional agency--
said, well, this is
what we have to do.
This is where the growth's going
to come, and so we've
got to feed this growth.
And so we said, what we need to
do is we need a new vision
of how this region can grow.
But we need, all at once, to
say, how about if we put the
growth somewhere else and
then fed it with a new
transportation system, one that
reinvested in choices--
walking, biking, transit--
and were realistic.
And I think this is before
we had the vision of how
technology can really help.
Also, again, it was '97.
So these were three of the
main things that our
organization started
doing at that time.
And we convinced our agencies
that this was lunacy to keep
planning in this way.
And we did the first
regional visioning
project in the country.
And they came up with a vision
that looked like this-- that
said, OK, yeah, let's grow
around walkable downtowns,
weather it's Mountain View or
even out in the suburban and
rural areas.
Let's plan to grow around
the walkable downtowns.
And even though that's not where
the growth is planned
now, let's create incentives
to make that happen.
Let's give money for walking and
biking in those downtowns
to make it attractive again.
So we created consensus on a lot
of these solutions amongst
a lot of nonprofits.
We kind of got it
into the media.
And then we put it into action
by going out into county sales
taxes or bridge tolls
and other ways.
And where there was money to
be found, where they were
going to be raising new money,
we inserted our voices.
This was a failed
measure in '98--
it was when we were just
coming on the scene--
that kind of had too
much money for
highways in Alameda County.
So we put together a coalition
that would have dueling
transit plans.
We said, if you support
a livable agenda, an
environmental agenda, folks
that opposed you last time
will all come on, and we will
agree to support it.
And that's exactly
what happened.
We had a protest.
We had to get outside
their doors.
On this one, they locked us out,
actually-- there were so
many of us--
out of their meeting.
But this is some low-income
folks from this group, BOSS,
talking with the Sierra Club
leader behind him, really
getting folks to
agree together.
They finally agreed that if we
can work together, fight for
the same stuff, and get things
that support both equity and
the environment, we would
get behind it.
When we announced our support
for it, four out of the five
county supervisors in Alameda
County said, wow, if you guys
are all supporting it, we'll
all get behind it.
And the papers covered it.
And from something that failed
with 58% of the vote in '98--
when the voters saw consensus,
supported what to them looked
pretty similar, but saw that
all of these groups were
supporting, it got
81% in 2000.
And so we did a very similar
thing on a lot of measures,
including in Santa Clara County,
to help build support
for a bridge toll increase
to fund public
transit across the bridges.
And so in those years up to
2004, we got a lot of funding
for transit expansion.
In fact, we kind of turned on
its head the old "let's spend
the money on roads because
there's such traffic" to say,
no, let's spend the money
on alternatives.
And 75% of the funding during
this time went for transit
expansion and almost the same
time for bike ped and smart
growth, as for highways.
There became this plan for
transit expansion in the area.
And then we said, wow, we better
grow smart around this.
We can't just put old parking
lots around all this transit.
So TransForm, working with
a number of foundations,
including some members here
from the Silicon Valley
Community Foundation, said,
let's help engage communities,
decide what the community should
look like as they grow.
And as they change, everybody
can envision something else
they'd want, whether it's
parks or a branch
library as we grow.
And we helped people to
realize, through some
transformations that
you'll see, that
people are not the problem.
If you want to bring 60 people
into your town, this is what
they look like.
They don't have to
look like this.
And it's when they look like
this that you want to reject
them and get them the hell out
of there, because they're
going to make parking hard,
they're going to make traffic.
But if you can get them onto
transit, they look like that.
If you get them onto bikes and
walking, they look like that.
So people are nice.
People like people, generally.
But it's when they come with all
of those cars-- so then,
how do we figure out
how to get them
there without the cars?
Well, one thing that we care
about is making sure that when
we do figure out how to grow
in these great places, and
they become nicer and nicer--
like we have many towns along
the peninsula are--
is that they stay available for
all folks, including the
lower-income folks who are
already there, and that we're
coming up with places and
policies that can have them
live there.
Here, we're identifying infill
parcels for dedicated
affordable housing.
And we did this in a lot of
places that we go and plan.
And then we bring folks along
with visualizations.
How can your place look
if we grow smart?
And how do you reduce traffic?
Who here, when you were younger,
or even now, read "A
Wrinkle In Time?"
Raise your hand.
Come on, don't be embarrassed.
It's a great book.
Great.
At least half the
crowd, again.
Not all the same folks as took
transit, though, this morning.
So a "Wrinkle In Time," one of
my favorite books, said--
the shortest distance between
two lines, what is it?
And the protagonist said,
well, I don't know.
It's a straight line.
You go a straight line,
it's the fastest.
And the prophet said, no, it's
bringing those lines together.
Transportation planning should
be about that, right?
So this is downtown
San Leandro.
That's what it looks
like today.
We said, how about if you bring
more of the things that
are spread out today together
so that people actually can
just walk between places?
And what if it starts
to look like this?
Suddenly, they say, oh, I'd
really like to come to
downtown if it looked
like that.
I never go to downtown.
I just go to the mall now.
They didn't notice the
seven-story buildings that
went in, because there
are trees.
And in fact, they don't care,
because it looks like a better
place to be.
And the folks that were still
skeptical said, well, what
about this affordable housing?
Aren't those criminals that
you're going to bring to our
town and ex-cons?
And I'm like, well actually,
it's the teachers that are
teaching your kid, it's the
nurse that just helped save
your life is the affordable
housing, and took them on
tours if they're rejecting.
And we did all these different
kind of tools.
And what we found was that
folks really started to
support these plans for bringing
these downtowns to
life, saving the open space,
and bring it here.
So real quickly now, this gets
to where I'm going to
hopefully engage you a little
bit in thinking about how we
can make a future that's better,
because that kind of
brought us up to some of
our current activities.
So we've got lots of
transit coming in.
We've got some great plans
for downtowns, more being
made all the time.
And there's a new California
dream happening.
And California captures
the imagination
of the United States.
It captures the imagination of
the world, especially with
what's happening in
Silicon Valley.
And when you look at what the
dream is, it's really not to
move out to my parents' house
in suburban Long Island near
the Green Acres Mall.
It's to be in a place where
you can get out and walk
around, get the kids in a
stroller, and be near parks.
And in fact, 64%, in a recent
survey, said that they'd
prefer that kind of urban or
semi-urban to a long commute.
Here's the thing.
It's really hard to
build this infill.
Just ask you mayor here.
It's really hard to build and
get approvals for these
things, in part because
we're planning for too
many cars for them.
So this shows you just what the
demand is expected to be
here for transit just in the
four largest metro areas in
California.
The demand is expected to be
almost 10 million units to
live near transit.
It's where folks coming out of
college want to be, it's where
folks finishing their work lives
want to be, and a lot of
us in between.
The blue bar is the supply.
We've got to figure out how
we're going to build this red
bar here if we want to meet
that supply in a way that
means we can live in
affordable, low
greenhouse gas places.
So how are we going to do it?
Well, I'm going to start with
the story of Rosie.
And this is not how we do it.
So Rosie came to work
with us this year.
She helps run our Safe Routes
to Schools Program.
She helps kids figure out
how to get to school.
She's had to bring these bikes
into her apartment.
She also has pretty damn high
rent in the Jack London Square
District of Oakland.
Now, why are her bikes stuck
in her apartment in very
scarce space?
Well, she's got two
parking spaces--
came with her rent-- but
she has no cars.
She started leaving them
in her parking spaces.
Building said, sorry, you can't
leave your bikes here.
This is for cars.
And so she's paying what's the
equivalent of $80,000 in
construction costs, what's
equivalent to at least $100 of
her rent, and she can't even
leave her bikes there.
And we're planning that kind of
community for a lot of our
downtown, still.
This is recently-built
Jack London Square.
Even if you wanted to build a
senior unit in a lot of these
places, you'd have to
buy two spaces.
So this is pretty fascinating
stuff.
If you took an eight-acre lot
and put that zoning code--
see, there are these zoning
codes that each city has--
and says, you've got to build
those 2.2 spaces, even if that
person doesn't want it.
And 8 out of the 14 cities down
here have this kind of,
you have to build at least to
code, because they think that
we were importing the suburbs
into our downtowns.
Here are some of the stats
that you would have.
You'd build to fit 800 units
on that eight acres.
But really, just because you're
near transit, building
high-density, you
only need 1.1.
Hell, Rosie doesn't have any.
You'd still have to build a
parking structure, though,
that would be expensive
for that 1.1.
But you'd be able to
build a lot less.
As you see, you'd be able to
save $12 million by building a
smaller structure, build
162 more units.
But now let's say you give out
free or discount transit
passes with each of the units.
You put CarShare in there so
people really can have just
one or zero cars.
You unbundle the parking, so
hey, if you don't want to use
it, you don't have
to pay for it.
And only when you need a
spot do you pay for it.
Your need goes down even more,
because that'll get more
people not to own cars.
And now you can pay $6 million
for those transit passes.
And we do this with VTA.
We kind of, through our
GreenTRIP certification
program, folks that are doing
this and giving out the free
transit, we say,
this is great.
They buy it for everybody
in the building.
They get a great discount.
And with that saving they're
getting from such a smaller
parking spot, they're able
to build more units
and have less parking.
And this green that you
can see means they
have a nicer building.
Instead of those big parking
lots, they've got storefronts.
They've got more units.
So that's part of
the solution.
So we go and we certify these
kind of buildings.
We show the community why they
get so many reductions.
We give out to the mayors and
others these certificates.
We get applause from
the community.
People understand there's low
greenhouse gas communities.
Here's one in San Jose, another
one in Berkeley.
And the impact of our pilot
project of these, we got five
of these developments built
that you give out transit
passes or have CarShare.
And the impact was amazing.
These five buildings--
some of them are under
construction now--
instead of putting money into
parking spaces that don't get
used, they're going to literally
be handing money to
transit agencies saying,
provide folks with--
here's their transit passes.
They're going to be driving
about 60% less, and folks are
going to be saving a huge amount
of money that they can
spend in the local community.
They can give to this kid's
local PTA, which is what we're
doing with some of our savings
that we're doing in my family.
How can we bring
this to scale?
How can we do billions for
transit agencies, millions of
fewer miles, and billions
of savings?
This is going to be a question
I have for you soon is, how
can Google folks
help with this?
One idea that we have, that
we're trying to advance, is
instead of having that
information be really hard to
get in technical--
Ann, do you want to stand
up for a second?
Ann Cheng goes out, works with
staff, and figures out these
numbers one by one.
How about, instead of that kind
of one-on-one consulting
that's so arduous, if we took
all the information that's in
Google Maps, Google Transit,
Walk Score, all these other
places that we can grab
information from, and automate
it so that folks would know,
on a given parcel, how much
parking's really needed.
If they can then go and say,
hey, what happens if we have
these toggles and we say, let's
give out transit passes,
let's do these other things.
And they can watch.
Developers can watch, community
members can watch.
They can watch as the amount
of miles would go down.
As you're doing these smarter
things, providing affordable
homes, the amount of
miles goes down.
So instead of fighting
affordable housing in your
community, you'd say, oh yeah,
this is actually a low
traffic, low greenhouse
gas strategy.
Giving out transit passes--
it sounds expensive--
but, oh I see, I'm saving
millions on parking.
So I could afford it
as a developer.
And in fact, cities could then
adopt this as a code.
Just say, oh, as long as they're
doing all of these
things, they can have
the reduced parking.
We won't make them
build those 2.2.
So what are some of the ideas
that you may have about how to
make this possible?
We think that this can
dramatically change how people
do it, and especially then if we
can figure out how to show
them these secondary benefits.
But what does this do
to our climate?
What does this do to things
like transit revenue?
So anyways, that's one of the
things we'd love to have folks
think about with us,
is how to do that.
But here is one that'll hit
home for many of you.
We've got a lot of
Google buses.
In fact, if you look at this
map on the right, somebody
took the liberty of mapping out
all of the Silicon Valley
private transit that happens.
Guess which one is the big,
yellow, gold one?
Those are the Google buses.
And the other ones are some
of the other companies.
Does somebody want to scream
out, who's on one of these
from San Francisco, how much
longer is it taking this year
than, say, two years ago?
OK, you raised your hand for--
just, you're on it.
But how much longer is
the trip sitting in
traffic these days?
AUDIENCE: I haven't
been here long.
STUART COHEN: OK, who's
been here a while?
AUDIENCE: So if I go home at
8:00 PM, it takes about 40
minutes on the bus.
This morning, coming in,
it took 70 minutes.
STUART COHEN: OK.
Half an hour of traffic delay.
And that's getting
more typical.
And that's going to grow.
I hate to say it--that's
going to grow.
It's going to make living in San
Francisco, at some point,
kind of hellish, to be honest.
Because even with Wi-Fi on the
bus, you really don't want to
be spending three hours
on it every day.
And so you're waiting there on
the corner, and this is 101.
This [INAUDIBLE].
And as the economy picks up,
this is going to be happening.
That's just because of
an economy pick-up.
That's not even with growth.
As we have growth, it's going to
be getting worse and worse.
There's the potential
to change this.
But because of kind of
stuck-in-the-box thinking and
policies, we may not be able to
unless we can all harness
our innovation and advocacy
to make a change.
Let me tell you what that
is real quickly.
There's something called carpool
lanes that have extra
space in them.
They've started to, in places,
say, you can come in here as a
solo driver with a toll.
And you could pay your way in.
So they're studying that
in the Bay Area.
You could see that the purple
lines are places that had
carpool lanes or are
building them soon.
Green is where there
aren't any.
And they're thinking, OK, let's
get some money to do it.
This is in San Mateo County.
And so we've got Google
around here.
And the amazing thing is,
though, you think--
well, let me just go up one.
If this is what it's going to
look like, why can't we just
take a lane?
Why don't we just take
one of these lanes?
These all have--
guess how many people
sit in each one of
these cars on average?
I mean, if you could divide
people into fractions.
AUDIENCE: 1.57
STUART COHEN: Yeah.
So 1.57.
Somebody really goddamn knows
their stats here.
That was very impressive.
He's a plant.
Somebody planted him.
AUDIENCE: That's the national
average for urban
commuting, as well.
STUART COHEN: Yeah.
And for commutes in the Bay
Area to work, it's 1.2.
That's kind of the average,
because that includes the
school commutes.
So 1.2.
And so you've got a Google
bus and other buses--
40, 50 folks sitting
behind that 1.2
person in front of you.
And each person gets
it much worse.
With each 10% increase, once
it's like this, of cars in the
road, it's a 40% increase in
delay, because they have to
slow down that much as
things get closer.
So why can't we just take this
lane and just say, as long as
we have more efficiency
in it--
if we're carrying, on average,
10 people per car-- instead of
2,000 people per hour, if we're
carrying 5,000 people,
let's just take it.
And you know why you can't?
I bet you know.
AUDIENCE: It's a lot
of complex reasons.
STUART COHEN: A lot of complex
reasons is right!
This guy knows everything.
But the most core reason is that
Caltrans had a really bad
experience over 30 years ago
in Los Angeles where they
tried to do a conversion of a
lane into a carpool lane.
There wasn't enough traffic on
it, and so it caused more
traffic in the lanes
next to it.
Of course, now it's different.
We've got technology.
We can let folks
in for a toll.
We can fill up that lane to make
sure we don't do it and
so it doesn't congest
the ones next to it.
And if you took 5,000 or 6,000
or 7,000 people and put it on
that lane, they'd all be
going faster, too.
So in this particular situation,
you're in luck if
you'd like to do a little
thinking with us, because next
year this is going to
be under study.
It's going to be one of the
first ones where Caltrans may
let us even study taking
a lane and
making it more efficient.
They can't conceptualize
San Francisco.
So that's the next piece of
advocacy is letting them think
through even the concept of
letting one of these HOT lanes
in San Francisco.
If you're interested in making
sure that that gets studied
and that we don't have to wait
to build a new lane-- because
that would be billions of
dollars and about 20 years
away before we could actually
build a lane down this whole
section, and let alone
in San Francisco--
then just make sure you sign
up with us afterward.
We want to have a study group
that gets them to make sure
they have a great alternative
there.
And then-- actually,
let me go back.
The other thing I want
them to re-think--
you see these little green
things on the end?
These tails?
They want to put big highways
out to the end of our region.
I guess right here.
I forgot there's one
behind me, too.
They want to bring in-- expand
all the way down to San Benito
and out to San Joaquin County--
they want to expand
it so that there's eight lanes
of highway lanes coming in
from currently four.
Now, what happens?
It's kind of like this
sink is full already.
Total congestion.
This sink is full.
What happens when you turn
on a new faucet?
Well, why would we want to
promote more housing in San
Benito for jobs here and
all of those folks
coming in by car?
So we would like to get the
notion across that we've got
to cap highway expansion,
especially
out to other regions.
But we can't do that
if people are going
to be stuck in traffic.
And that's where another
Google project
potentially comes in.
So this is something that's
relatively new, of course--
thinking about this at Google--
but is making pretty
fast advances.
I'm trying to remember--
it's not Scrabble.
I can't figure out-- anybody
know what game that is?
AUDIENCE: Dominos.
STUART COHEN: Oh, OK.
Good.
Thank you.
So this is becoming a bit more
of a reality, right?
It's not quite as cheesy as
this, but this is becoming
more of a reality.
Hundreds of thousands of miles
logged on this stuff.
And this is Volvo testing
it out in Europe.
But if we had vehicles like
this, we certainly wouldn't
need the highway expansion
that's in there going all the
way to San Benito County.
And since they don't think
they're going to have the
money for that for 20, 25
years when this kind of
long-term future may become
a reality, why are we
planning them out?
And why are we saying we have
a need for over $100 billion
of new highway expansion money
when our state is going broke?
So that's just a thought to
leave you with as I just go on
to one or two more topics
real quickly now.
What is long-distance travel?
I think some of you might know
where this is going.
Our state is growing to
50 million pretty
soon from 38 million.
It's going to go up to 60
million at some point.
And if you thought it's getting
hard to travel--
a lot of emissions now--
just wait until then.
So some of you might have heard
about this fast train,
220 miles an hour.
And it would go--
it is actually starting
construction next year on the
slow part of this train.
I'm not going to go into
details, but happy to talk to
you afterwards about it--
to start a little
segment here.
But by 2022, there might
be a fast train
connecting this segment.
And by 2030, all the way--
San Francisco, Los Angeles.
But we don't have the
money for it.
That's probably the biggest
problem with this.
There needs to be some better
planning for it, too.
We'll be the first
to admit it.
And you can go look
up our website.
We've got a long report on how
they can do it better.
But if we can get it right, it's
not just a fast way to
get to Los Angeles.
It would connect our 24
largest city centers.
And instead of these airport
economies that you see, we
would help to revitalize our
downtowns, especially in the
Central Valley, as we grow
to that 60 million.
When BART came out, and it had
120,000 people riding it,
people said, this was
a waste of money.
And now, as it's exploding at
the seams with 350,000 riders
and heading higher, people
are saying we
don't have enough BART.
And I think it would be
the same thing here.
This is $60 billion more
needed, less than
that highway proposal.
So I think, in part, we're
just getting where we're
putting our money wrong.
And we might have a place
to get some of
the money for this.
So here's my favorite
picture in my job
here is our old governor.
An unlikely hero.
He plays funny characters.
I think he's in another movie
again playing a sheriff soon.
But he's an unlikely
hero for us.
But actually, one of his
lasting legacies--
OK, besides the plant in the
front, who knows what's
happening tomorrow that
is going to be pretty
groundbreaking, putting
California in the news again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STUART COHEN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: The auction.
STUART COHEN: Yeah.
There's a cap-and-trade
auction.
We are going to start selling
the right to emit greenhouse
gases in the state to industrial
polluters, and
they're going to be having some
allowances, selling off
some of those rights.
In 2015, the gasoline
refiner is going to
have to do that, also.
We're probably going to be
raising somewhere $4 billion
or $5 billion a year just from
transportation fuels to give
those folks the right to emit.
My organization, TransForm, has
a proposal that would help
to spend a lot of that
money on transit--
walk, bike, ped-- to
make some of these
features we saw a reality.
Because what we saw is--
remember how much we saw people
can save just in the
Bay Area? $10 billion a year,
$30 billion across the state
annually if we all have
more choices.
If we could take some of that
money and document those
savings, as opposed to just
giving them to transit and not
documenting it, I think we can
build support for this program
before it goes under politically
and because it
ends in 2020.
That was all they had the
politics to pull off.
And if we can do that, Governor
Schwarzenegger really
may have helped to save the
planet, because a lot of
people are looking at what
California does.
So another thing we'd love for
your innovation to help with,
is how we map out what is
happening with this
cap-and-trade money, with this
greenhouse gas money on the
transportation sector so
people actually see the
benefits, and we're able to
quantify the financial
benefits for it and build
that support.
Couple-- a few slides I'll just
show, and then we could
have some conversation.
Once you get to your places on
high-speed rail, how do we
make our local buses quicker?
One option is for bus rapid
transit, which is to give
dedicated lanes to buses.
This is on El Camino.
It does squeeze down,
sometimes,
some of the car lanes.
But there's lots of flexible
ways that we can have it.
Buses are only getting more
expensive to operate as we get
more and more traffic
on our urban roads.
How do we get the next
generation doing this?
Well, this is one of my
favorite programs.
It started in Marin County
12 years ago.
And then we helped to start
one of the first urban
programs at TransForm
in Oakland.
And we're now at 90 schools and
teach kids how to walk and
bike to school safely.
A lot of the parents don't know
how to do this anymore.
I put my kid through the
training, because I was scared
to hell of having my 10-year-old
on the street.
Even though she'd go with me,
I was scared to hell to have
her go alone.
And so I have the pros do the
training, have contests,
encouragement, make more bike
lanes to the schools.
We got a great program going,
convinced our regional agency,
MTC, that this should be part
of a climate program.
20% of the trips in
the mornings are
getting kids to school.
It's absurd.
We're filling up our skies with
pollution and making the
streets more dangerous just
to get kids to school.
We convinced them to have
it be a climate program.
It's now in all nine counties
of the Bay Area, and it's
really starting to spread
across the country.
It's a fabulous program.
The other thing that's great
about it is once kids are
trained in how to do
this, they get to
do it in other areas.
And I just want to close with
a really fun thing that
happened four days ago.
I was in Washington
with my family.
And my wife and kids
were there first.
And they had taken taxis around,
the day before, from
museum to monument--
a day of taxis.
Nice.
Supporting the local taxi
industry, but also filling the
skies with pollution.
And passing this--
it's a bike share enabled with
innovation and technology,
because you just do it all
swiping credit cards.
They've got 150 stations now
where you can go and get bikes
throughout Washington.
You can sign up for
a day or a year.
My kids said, dad,
can't we do this?
We're sick of being strapped
into taxis.
It was our way to get
around Washington.
There's my little [? Shira ?]
begging, saying, come on.
And I was like, ah, we
don't have helmets.
Mostly we're going to be
biking on the mall.
And so sure enough, we
rented them out.
Just swipe a little credit card,
and you just take them
out of the machine.
Mostly stayed on the mall,
on these wide sidewalks.
You get to your destination.
This was to the Holocaust
Museum.
You just find a bike rack.
You just snap it back in,
and you walk away.
It knows which bike
you brought in.
It knows how long
you had it out.
As long as it's under half an
hour, there's no extra charge.
And then I separated
from my wife.
She stayed there.
We went to New York and met
her back last night in
California.
And the kids said, how was
the rest of your trip?
And she said, great.
And their first question
wasn't, how was
it seeing your friends?
How were the other museums
that you went to?
They said, did you take
out the bikes again?
That was what they remembered
from this.
They went to the White House.
They went to the Washington
Monument.
This is what really inspired
them about the trip to
Washington.
And kids are sick of being
strapped into the backseat.
And what they're finding now is
that in the last 10 years,
kids 18 to 24 are driving 25%
less, delaying getting their
licenses, more attached to
their smart phones than
identifying with a car.
And we have this chance to
use the innovation that's
happening here, to use a lot of
the technology, and to mix
it with some of this advocacy
to disrupt systems.
The same disruption that I saw
in New York with Sandy and the
same disruption we're seeing to
communities, We can change
it and go back, and instead of
these highway plans, go to
high-speed rail--
done right, of course.
We can get kids to be much
more focused on this.
And we're helping to
bring BikeShare--
that same climate program that
we advocated for is going to
bring bike sharing to Mountain
View next year.
It's going to be along
the Caltrain line.
And I think, hey, New York
is going to have it.
It's going to be called Citi
Bike, because Citibank is
going to sponsor it.
I would love to see
Mountain View and
beyond have Google Bike.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STUART COHEN: Well, you guys
have it for yourself.
I'm going to go grab
one of these below.
But how about having
it for others, too?
Anyway, I do think that we are
on the cusp of really being
able to make a new one--
things like Zipcar,
RelayRides.
There's just so much we can
do with technology to do a
great-- actually, just even
showing this, with car
sharing, we can have
it be all around.
Just go get your
neighbor's car.
There's just so many
things we can do.
So I just wanted to
end it there.
I know it was a lot of
information very fast, but
it's really--
I think if we can get some of
your folks who are already
with Google Transit, having
its own disruptive and
wonderful influence on folks
there, can be a very big
impact on how we grow.
Yeah.
So why don't we open it
up for questions.
AUDIENCE: So the project
of the fast train to
LA is really awesome.
And my friend was to China and
their trains cover Beijing to
Shanghai in, like,
three hours.
But why does it take like
20, whatever years you
said, to build it?
Why China could build one
in five, right, or--
so what's different?
AUDIENCE: A lot of
complex reasons.
STUART COHEN: A lot of
First off, there's definitely
the money.
High-speed rail is going to cost
$68 billion here with the
current plan.
And we don't have the money
in our broke state.
So the money is one.
And then environmental review
and getting it through
communities and doing the
planning right is the other.
If we put our mind to it, we can
do it in faster than that.
And actually, if we wanted to
take carbon fees and put it
towards high-speed rail, it
could be done faster.
But I wouldn't want it done less
than 10, because we want
to get the planning right and
really engage communities.
Real quickly.
AUDIENCE: This is sort of
a specific question.
But I live in Menlo Park, and
they are looking at sites for
lower-income, higher-density
housing.
And they have maps
very similar to
some you showed there.
And there are people who, sort
of like you alluded to a
little bit in your talk, were
concerned about more people
and more density bringing
in more traffic.
And you made a joke about
bank robbers and stuff.
How do you plan to address those
kinds of objections from
people who are uncomfortable?
Because there's a lot of people
in the community who
tend to just immediately jump
on things like that.
And it's hard to educate them.
And I don't know what facts
you have to really back up
your statement.
STUART COHEN: So we have great
facts as part of our great
communities collaborative--
we've got a communities
collaborative website.
There's kind of everything from
fliers that you give out
showing who these folks are.
People should introduce
themselves, and they could
even, in the Menlo Park
meetings, ask for who is
making that much money.
But we also take people on tours
of affordable housing.
We have them meet the people
that are in them.
But I think there's nothing
like that one-on-one
experience of actually seeing
it in other places.
A lot of the affordable housing
is now LEED certified,
energy efficient, good
looking, with
great people in it.
And it's a matter of, actually,
I think that
experience of-- we take
city-elected officials and
planners to actually
go to other
affordable housing sites.
AUDIENCE: Can you demonstrate
that the people who would be
in these housing units would
not be driving as much?
STUART COHEN: On average.
That's one of the things that
we do, is we bring in the
averages and show how they'll
have, depending on where,
about half a vehicle per
household, depending on the
sizes and everything.
There's a couple of
other questions.
Last one?
AUDIENCE: I also find a lot of
these timelines really kind of
disconcerting in terms
of, like, 20 years,
30 years, et cetera.
And it sounds like part
of this is financial.
It might also be because of the
scale of the projects, but
are there efforts underway for
having the private sector
supplement a bit of
these projects?
And then also, maybe having
more, like you were saying,
test segments so that the
timelines don't seem so
enormous and we can
see benefits?
STUART COHEN: Yes.
We need innovation and then
replication to be part of the
DNA of our government sector.
And then we definitely need
private sector support, both
developers, companies
like Google.
So absolutely.
And we can talk afterwards
about it.
We have to end now.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, let's
thank Stuart.
Thank you very much
for a great talk.
[APPLAUSE]
STUART COHEN: Appreciate it.